[Musique]
si vous le refusez monsieur c'est une
amende donc c'est pas raisonnable ici
c'est une amendement
je suis non voyant c'est un chien guide
vous êtes obligé de le prendre monsieur
c'est quoi votre principe
alors elle est incroyable cette histoire
anthony est avec nous et son chien nepia
Anthony chef d'entreprise non voyant a
été agressé par uber vous avez 33 ans
vous séparez jamais de nez bien votre
chien guide qui est là on va revenir sur
ce qui s'est passé il est 8h45 lorsque
vous commandez un VTC sur la plateforme
uber
tranquille comme d'habitude vous le
faites souvent tous les matins parce que
j'emmène ma fille à l'école et puis
également le soir puisque je la récupère
tous les matins vous êtes avec nepia
tous les matins tous les jours même je
suis avec mes Pia parce que nepia c'est
bien sûr c'est mes yeux c'est la
compensation au handicap au sens de la
loi mais c'est surtout c'est surtout ma
fidèle compagne de route alors
vous êtes vous êtes que avec nepia ce
matin là je suis avec nepia et je suis
avec ma fille de 4 ans ainsi que sa
grand-mère que je dois dormir à la
maison et que je dois déposer chez elle
donc vous êtes 3 plus ce chien on est
trois plus le chien vous vous signalez
avant uber vous le faites sur l'appli
non que je suis non voyant non que vous
avez un chien non non parce que il y a
tellement de refus que je lui donne si
je dis ça la liberté de refuser ça c'est
incroyable ça vous voyez déjà ça
première info c'était bien parce que
cette histoire est incroyable on va
avoir la vidéo si vous dort joignez
tout se passe bien d'habitude quand même
bah
on va dire que un cas sur trois se passe
mal
ça veut quand même dire qu'il y a deux
cas sur trois qui se passe bien et je
tiens à saluer quand même la profession
des VTC des taxis pour son entièreté ou
en tout cas ça grande globalité qui fait
correctement son travail c'est important
de le dire c'est important c'est
important de le dire une fois sur place
donc vous arrivez avec vous vous êtes
les quatre au départ il voit tout de
suite que vous avez une épia avec vous
bien au départ il fait monter les la
petite et votre non au départ il voit
qu'il y a le chien et c'est à peine s'il
dit bonjour C'est je prends pas les
chiens monsieur désolé d'accord
je lui explique que c'est un chien guide
que je suis non-voyant que j'ai ma
petite fille de 4 ans qu'il faut que
j'emmène à l'école donc à ce moment là
j'ai planté les faits j'ai planté le
décor et ensuite c'est lui qui en est
juge alors donc là
normalement légalement il est obligé
d'accepter le chien j'ai absolument il y
a la loi qui autorise à prendre les
transports sinon il y a une amende de
450 euros c'est prévu dans la loi il n'a
pas le droit de refuser et dans le
règlement comment il se justifie du juge
j'aime pas les chiens non au début il
dit j'ai pas ça dans l'application
son téléphone comme si je pouvais le
voir
d'accord
il avait pas compris
ensuite
je lui dis mais pourquoi vous refusez
vous êtes obligé de le prendre si vous
le prenez pas je vais être obligé
d'appeler la police la police ce sera
une amende c'est bête c'est bien de lui
dire ça en plus et il me dit non non
mais moi j'ai un principe donc j'essaye
de comprendre je lui mets quel est votre
principe il me répond pas et puis il me
dit non mais en fait je suis malade je
suis allergique contre les chiens
pourtant j'en ai un alors c'est pas
parce que je suis allergique au choc il
faut que tout le monde en ait un et que
et que moi-même enfin je dois en avoir
un mais l'argument est totalement
fallacieux parce que je l'ai entendu
plusieurs fois alors il y a une passante
infirmière vous allez voir toutes les
vidéos sont incroyables qui entend votre
conversation confirme même au chauffeur
qui est dans l'obligation de prendre
votre chien à bord de son véhicule
regardez
[Musique]
et lorsqu'il s'aperçoit que vous êtes en
train de filmer il s'énerve et vous
demande de supprimer la vidéo il réagit
comment
en fait préalablement je lui précise
quand même qu'il se rassure que je vais
mettre le chien dans le coffre d'accord
parce que je sais la contrainte que cela
représente pour un chauffeur que de
nettoyer
éventuellement effectivement il y a
vraiment des gens qui sont allergiques
le concernant je m'interroge parce que
c'est pas l'argument qu'il m'avance en
premier donc spontanément je propose à
tous les chauffeurs que le chien aille
dans le coffre
ça je pense que ça désamorce toute
complication bien sûr et
lui du coup me dit oui mais le chien va
dans le coffre pas de problème donc je
vais vers le coffre on ouvre le coffre
il décale en sac je fais mon ténépia et
là il commence à me toucher alors
d'abord lorsqu'il s'aperçoit que vous
êtes en train de filmer il vous demande
de supprimer la vidéo
je n'arrêterai pas de filmer regardez
comme ça moi je vais couvrir derrière
alors ça commence à une bonne ambiance
et donc il finit par accepter votre
chien il veut tout de même faire
tout de même faire une demande de
réclamation auprès de la plateforme uber
avant je sais pas ce qu'ils vont
réclamer bah c'est ça pourquoi c'est pas
compris à ce moment là c'est
complètement incompréhensible il me dit
je te prends t'inquiète pas je te laisse
pas dans la merde
il accepte que je suis un monde dans le
coffre et en fait il me demande que le
chien descende moi je suis dans une
incompréhension totale à côté de ça j'ai
ma petite fille de 4 ans qui regarde ça
c'est un obsession
elle est elle est témoin de ça et je
dois l'emmener à l'école je suis à la
bourre j'ai un rendez-vous après enfin
tout ça on parle menthe pendant des
minutes et des minutes entières pour que
monsieur fasse une déclaration elle fait
une réclamation über tout je ne sais pas
quel est l'objectif qu'il cherche
derrière
alors pendant qu'il fait cette
réclamation vous faites monter votre
chien
et là ça dérape totalement qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
tout de suite en fait je j'ouvre la
porte de l'habitacle il me dit non mais
c'est bon attends ils veulent le chien
va dans le coffre je sais pas très bien
dans le coffre donc on ouvre de nouveau
le coffre et là il me retouche de
nouveau c'est au moment où je ne touche
pas j'étais déjà dit de pas me toucher
et moi je comprends plus rien il Reva
enfin il retourne vers l'infirmière
et à ce moment je me dis bon ça y est en
fait il nous prend
il va ouvrir donc à la grand-mère et à
ma fille de l'autre côté pour qu'on
puisse installer siège auto on a un
siège auto pliable et moi de mon côté je
vais pour ouvrir l'habitacle je me dis
ça y est
il m'a dit je te prends je te laisse pas
dans la merde bien sûr je fais monter le
chien le chien se couche par terre comme
il a l'habitude de le faire
à sa place et à mes pieds donc là vous
êtes vous êtes devant vous êtes où à
l'arrière d'accord
à ce moment là il est en train de faire
la demande de réclamation c'est parce
qu'il réclame je sais même pas s'il fait
la réclamation uber enfin en tout cas je
sais pas ça là vous faites monter votre
chien et là ça dérape totalement
conducteur s'en prend même annéepia
regardez c'est pas sérieux non c'est bon
je peux y aller parce que ma fille elle
est en retard à
je suis désolé
d'accord
qu'est-ce qui se passe concrètement pour
tes spectateurs au moment où je fais mon
ténépia il le voit et là il vient vers
moi furieux vous l'avez entendu il me
saute dessus il m'attrape par les
épaules il me met un coup au niveau des
côtes et donc là je sais qu'il y a ma
fille qui est toujours là qui regarde je
me dis surtout reste calme reste digne
et donc je le plaque sur sa voiture et
je lui dis tu te calmes mais non je lui
dis ça cinq fois je lui dis tu te calmes
et au moment où je ne sens plus de
résistance de sa part je le lâche et là
il fait le tour du véhicule il ouvre la
porte opposée à celle qui que j'occupais
et il s'en prend à nepia moi il faut
comprendre qu'à ce moment là je ne vois
pas je ne vois pas ce qu'il fait à mon
chien évidemment je suis comme vous je
ressens de la haine de la
derrière mais surtout une fois que cette
situation commence à redescendre
je fais le tour de la voiture et je
reviens je retourne au niveau de ma
fille pour faire barrage et et la
protéger de ça comment ça se termine
cette affaire ça se termine que il
continue à parler donc je lui dis monde
dans ta voiture en fait la voiture où je
te monte dans ta voiture mais pas tant
va-t'en parce que
là tu allais trop loin
et
alors il
refuse au départ il veut appeler la
police il veut porter plainte il est
persuadé que c'est moi qui l'ai agressé
[Musique]
il faut savoir que ce monsieur a porté
plainte contre moi pour violence vous
avez porté plaindre aussi j'ai porté
plainte bien sûr refus de prendre un
chien guide violent sur personne
on a affaire à un homme là
un animal exactement devant votre fille
en plus de 4 ans
vous êtes donc remonté chez vous vous
avez laissé votre chien chez vous après
pourquoi
parce qu'il fallait que j'enchaîne la
journée et que à un moment je veux bien
combatifs à la maison vous êtes vous
avez rappelé un autre uber j'ai rappelé
un autre humeur c'est incroyable je vous
jure je j'hallucine c'est qui j'ai posé
la question j'ai aimé monsieur si
j'étais venu avec mon chien est-ce que
vous l'aurez accepté il m'a dit non non
je prends pas les chiens ça leur fait
une belle pub
c'est fou ce que c'est ce qu'on entend
Anthony
non mais on hallucine parce que ici ça
ça on peut on peut pas le laisser passer
et c'est fou ce que c'est que le
chauffeur a également porté plainte donc
contre Anthony selon lui c'est Anthony
qui l'agressé regardez toi
attends je regarde
il y a pas de souci monsieur je
l'accepte finalement comme je trouve
comment ça vous êtes handicap il y a pas
de problème
mais vous voulez insistez vous montez de
la voiture vous m'agressez
voilà c'est c'est incroyable alors donc
après ça dure combien de temps cette
affaire euh bah selon la vidéo au total
10 minutes quand c'est long pour moi ça
m'a paru une être une éternité vous avez
eu peur pour nepia pour vous pour votre
fille pour moi non pour nepia oui pour
ma fille absolument elle vous en a parlé
depuis ce qu'elle vous a dit
papa pourquoi le monsieur a refusé mes
Pia
pourquoi il a
il s'en est pris et pourquoi il t'a
sauté dessus et tu as hurlé dessus
tu sais dans la vie il y a des gens qui
ont peur de tout un tas de choses
c'est comme certaines de tes copines
elles ont elles ont peur des chiens et
elles ont appris à connaitre elles ont
plus peur des chiens et Monsieur c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'il avait peur de ne pas et peu à peu
et bien il apprendra peut-être avec ses
erreurs que il en a fait une grosse un
bon souvenir moi ce que j'entends et
c'est une leçon admirable Anthony
franchement c'est vous avez été
admirable vous êtes encore admirable ce
soir si si franchement c'est vrai parce
que nous on est spectateur aussi pour
soigner merci Anthony d'avoir été la
version Anthony et merci à mes plat